This is 99% Invisible. I'm Vivian Lay in this week for Roman Mars. I was raised in a Vietnamese household, which means I was practically born with a karaoke mic in my hand. Birthdays, family reunions, funerals, Sunday mornings after the Raiders lost, all good reasons to whip out the karaoke machine. And one of the things that I remember most vividly
这里是 99% Invisible。我是薇薇安·莱，本周代班罗曼·马尔斯。我在一个越南家庭长大，这意味着我手里几乎生来就握着卡拉OK麦克风。生日、家庭聚会、葬礼、突袭者队输球后的周日早晨，这些都是拿出卡拉OK机的绝佳理由。而我记忆中最深刻的事情之一，
during these formative mid-90s moments was watching the videos that played during the karaoke tracks my parents were singing along too. They were mostly stock footage synchronized to the music. You know, people on a beach, people sailing boats, people in a hot air balloon, pretty generic stuff. Every time I hear the song listen to the rhythm of the falling rain, I could still see freestyle roller skaters weaving through cones in an urban park. These videos were like watching the equivalent of hotel art. Something to look at, not necessarily something to think about.
在这些上世纪90年代中期性格成型的时光里，就是看着我父母正在合唱的卡拉OK曲目播放时的视频。它们大多是与音乐同步的素材片段。你知道的，海滩上的人、开船的人、热气球里的人，相当千篇一律的东西。每当我听到《听雨的节奏》（Listen to the Rhythm of the Falling Rain）这首歌时，我依然能看到自由式轮滑选手在城市公园的锥筒中穿梭。这些视频就像是酒店艺术的同义词。只可远观，不一定需要深思。
In other words, they were nothing like the karaoke videos that Brian Raftery was watching. when he was in his 20s. I definitely remember nights and times when I was singing when everyone would just kind of turn their head toward the video because they were so strange and they're so ambitious and they're so weird.
换句话说，它们和布赖恩·拉夫特里（Brian Raftery）在20岁时看的卡拉OK视频完全不同。我确实记得有些夜晚和时刻，当我唱歌时，每个人都会把头转向屏幕，因为它们太诡异了，太雄心勃勃了，也太奇怪了。
And some of them look really great. Brian is a culture writer and author of the book, Don't Stop Believe in, how karaoke conquered the world and changed my life. Brian's entry point to karaoke came in the late 1990s. He and his friends were living in New York City when they discovered a little
而且其中有些看起来真的很棒。布赖恩是一位文化作家，也是《别停止相信：卡拉OK如何征服世界并改变了我》（Don't Stop Believing: How Karaoke Conquered the World and Changed My Life）一书的作者。布赖恩接触卡拉OK是在20世纪90年代末。他和朋友们住在纽约市，当时他们发现了一家小小的
dive called Village Karaoke. It was during these late-night excursions that he realized the karaoke videos playing at Village were on a whole other level. Like the Benny and the Jets video, you can interpret that song, 85 million ways, but the video we remembered, for some reason,
地下酒吧，名叫“村庄卡拉OK”（Village Karaoke）。正是在这些深夜的外出中，他意识到在“村庄”播放的卡拉OK视频完全处于另一个水平。就像《贝尼和喷气机》（Bennie and the Jets）那个视频，你可以对那首歌做出85万种解读，但不知为什么，我们记住的视频，
was like a mom luring a bunch of kids slowly to a plate full of cookies, and I'm like, what the hell does this do with Benny and the Jets? No Benny, no Jets. It wasn't like these videos were unrelated stock footage just thrown over music. These are all originally produced short films, equipped with their own storylines, characters, and tangential
就像一个妈妈慢慢引诱一群孩子去拿一盘饼干，而我在想，这跟《贝尼和喷气机》到底有什么关系？没有贝尼，也没有喷气机。这些视频可不是随便扔在音乐上面的不相关素材。这些全都是原创制作的短片，配备了它们自己的故事情节、角色，以及对歌曲歌词的偏门
interpretations of the song's lyrics. And there were literally thousands of videos like this. There's a very strange video that we used to talk about all the time for Paul McCartney's Ebony and Ivory, which was really, I don't know if it's problematic or not, but it was like there's a black man walking a white dog and then a white man walking a black dog, and then they become friends. It is trying to be true to the spirit. of this, you know, Paul McCartney, Stevie Wonder do it. But it makes no sense that it's a dog park. Some of these karaoke videos were clearly bananas,
解读。而且这样的视频 literalmente（字面意思）有上千个。有一个我们过去经常讨论的非常奇怪的视频，是保罗·麦卡特尼（Paul McCartney）的《黑与白》（Ebony and Ivory），这真的很——我不知道这算不算有争议，但它的情节就像是一个黑人遛着一只白狗，然后一个白人遛着一只黑狗，接着他们成了朋友。它试图忠于这首歌的精神，你知道的，保罗·麦卡特尼和史蒂维·旺德（Stevie Wonder）的合作。但把它设定在狗公园里根本说不通。其中一些卡拉OK视频显然荒谬绝伦，
but they were not lacking an ambition. Actors were hired, locations were scouted, lighting was designed, and a lot of them were shot on actual film stock. Brian wanted to know who had made these, and why go through all the effort? I was just kind of like, this is weird that, like, this is a video that, like, we're just here as a goof, and someone put a lot of time and effort
但它们并不缺乏野心。他们雇用了演员，勘察了外景，设计了灯光，其中许多都是用真正的胶片拍摄的。布赖恩想知道是谁制作了这些视频，为什么要费这么大的劲？我当时就觉得，这太奇怪了，这居然是一个视频，我们只是去那里瞎胡闹，而有人却投入了大量的时间和精力，
to make this video for this haul and oats song that we're all drunkenly singing in a tiny room. As it turns out, these weirdo karaoke videos were kind of their own micro-movement of filmmaking. It only lasted a handful of years and is only remembered by a handful of people, but it gave a generation of aspiring filmmakers something that barely exists anymore,
为这首我们大家在一间小房间里醉醺醺地唱着的大厅与燕麦乐队（Hall & Oates）的歌制作了这段视频。事实证明，这些怪异的卡拉OK视频算是他们自己的微型电影制作运动。它只持续了短短几年，也只有少数人还记得，但它给一代有抱负的电影制作人提供了一种现在几乎不复存在的东西，
a paying gig where they could just mess around and figure out how to make stuff. It's about as close to an outside of, of Hollywood, Hollywood project as you can get. Some videos were good, some were bad, and several were so bad that they were awesome. And I had to know more about where they came from. The story of these videos actually originated about a decade before Brian discovered them at Village Karaoke.
一份有偿的工作，他们可以在那里尽情摸索，弄清楚如何制作东西。这大概是你能找到的最接近独立于好莱坞、好莱坞项目的东西了。有些视频很好，有些很糟，还有几个糟得无以复加，以至于棒极了。我不得不去深入了解它们的出处。这些视频的故事实际上起源于布赖恩在“村庄卡拉OK”发现它们的大约十年前。
Back in the 1980s, the world of consumer electronics was exploding. Personal computers, the Walkman, camcorders, fax machines, the Game Boy. It was like a shiny new toy was coming out on a monthly basis. And Neil Altnew wanted in. I basically was a sales and marketing exec. And I introduced a lot of products to the United States. One day in 1988, Neil was flipping through the New York Times, and he saw a job ad that intrigued him.
早在20世纪80年代，消费电子世界正在爆炸式发展。个人电脑、随身听、摄像机、传真机、Game Boy。就像每个月都有闪亮的新玩具问世一样。而尼尔·阿尔特纽（Neil Altnew）想要分一杯羹。我基本上是个销售和市场高管。我向美国引进了许多产品。1988年的某一天，尼尔正在翻阅《纽约时报》，他看到了一则引起他兴趣的招聘广告。
And they were looking for somebody, for some sort of a startup in the East Coast. The company that put out that ad was Pioneer, the Japanese Electronics Corporation. They were looking for someone to head up a brand-new division specifically in America. Neil applied, and when he got an interview, his wife drove down with him to the pioneer offices in Manhattan.
他们正在寻找某个人，为了东海岸的某种初创公司。发布那则广告的公司是日本电子企业先锋（Pioneer）。他们正在寻找负责人，专门在美国建立一个全新的部门。尼尔申请了，当他获得面试机会时，他的妻子开车和他一起去了曼哈顿的先锋办公室。
Well, you know, maybe two hours passed. I came down and I said, this is a really interesting product. And she said, what is it? And I said, it's this thing called karaoke. She said, what is it? Karaoke, what is that? Karaoke had been around for over a decade at this point. But back in the 1980s, it was still pretty unknown in the West.
嗯，你知道的，大概过去了两个小时。我走下来，我说，这是一个非常有趣的产品。她问，是什么？我说，是个叫卡拉OK的东西。她说，那是什么？卡拉OK，那是什么？到这个时候，卡拉OK已经存在了十多年。但在20世纪80年代，它在西方仍然鲜为人知。
It was huge in Asia, though, particularly. in Japan where Pioneer was headquartered. The word karaoke itself is Japanese, meaning empty orchestra. If you go to Japan, every little bar, there was 800,000 bars in Japan, believe it or not. But every bar had to have karaoke in it. And actually, a big reason why karaoke was already so popular in Japan was because of Pioneer's karaoke technology. A few years before Neil joined the company,
不过它在亚洲非常火爆，特别是
Pioneer completely revolutionized the karaoke game by releasing the first-ever karaoke Laserdisc player. For those under the age of 37, Laserdisc was one of the lesser-known combatants in the home video format wars of the 70s and 80s. Picture a DVD the size of a vinyl record. And I've got one on my hand right now. It's a disc looks like an LP record.
对于37岁以下的人来说，激光视盘是70、80年代家庭视频格式大战中不太为人知的参战者之一。想象一下黑胶唱片大小的DVD。我手里现在就有一个。这是一个看起来像LP唱片的盘片。
It's silver, and it has information on both sides. Okay, and there's 28 videos. on each disc. Back then, when home video was first emerging, VHS, Betamax, and Laserdisc were all battling it out to be the dominant consumer technology. VHS and Beta turned out to be exponentially more popular for the home movie watching experience. And videotape won the war. Laserdisc only was able to capture maybe 1% in the market.
它是银色的，两面都有信息。好的，每个盘片上有28个视频。当时，当家庭录像刚兴起时，VHS、Betamax和Laserdisc都在争夺主导消费技术的地位。事实证明，VHS和Beta对于家庭看电影的体验来说要受欢迎得多，呈指数级增长。录像带赢得了这场战争。Laserdisc只抢占了大约1%的市场份额。
But the video market is so huge. 1% of the market is very significant. So Pioneer says, you know what? Maybe not so much for movies, but karaoke, yeah. Because nobody else is doing it. So we're all alone. So we'll take 1% in the market all alone. When it came to something like karaoke,
但视频市场实在是太大了。1%的市场份额非常显著。所以先锋公司说，你知道吗？也许电影方面不太多，但卡拉OK，行。因为没有别人在做。所以我们是孤军奋战。因此我们将独自拿下这1%的市场份额。当谈到像卡拉OK这样的东西时，
Laserdisc had a superpower that gave it an edge over VHS or beta. A laser disc could jump around to individual chapters on the disc. Again, like a giant DVD. This made it well suited for searching for individual karaoke tracks if they were listed as chapters, like you would on a jukebox. It was a technology that fit the art form. Pioneer said, you know what, for a karaoke, application. This is perfect.
Laserdisc有一个超能力，让它在面对VHS或Beta时占有了优势。激光视盘可以在盘片上的各个章节之间跳转。再次说明，就像一个巨大的DVD一样。这使它非常适合搜索单个卡拉OK曲目，如果它们像点唱机那样被列为章节的话。这是一种契合这种艺术形式的技术。先锋公司说，你知道吗，对于卡拉OK应用来说，这太完美了。
Essentially, all you need for karaoke are two things, a backing track and the lyrics to the song displayed on the screen. But when Pioneer manufactured these discs for the Japanese market, they also decided to include one additional element, a karaoke music video that went along with each track. I think that the original concept of using those videos in Japan was to basically sell laser discs. Laser discs were known for having really good picture resolution, way better than its competitors, VHS, or Betamax. Pioneer in Japan figured it would be a complete waste not to put a nice-looking video up on the screen.
本质上，卡拉OK只需要两样东西：伴奏音乐以及显示在屏幕上的歌曲歌词。但当先锋公司为日本市场制造这些光盘时，他们还决定加入一个额外的元素——与每首曲目相配的卡拉OK音乐录影带。我认为在日本使用这些视频的最初概念基本上是为了销售激光视盘。激光视盘以拥有非常好的图像分辨率而闻名，比它的竞争对手VHS或Betamax好得多。日本的先锋公司觉得，如果在屏幕上放一个好看的视频，那就太浪费了。
And Neil says when Pioneer decided to expand to the American market and get Laser Karaoke into American bars, they copied that same formula. They had a lot of success in Japan with it that way, and they wanted to replicate their success in the United States, and they felt that this is the way we did it in Japan. We've got to do it in the United States the same way. But it couldn't be exactly the same.
尼尔说，当先锋公司决定拓展美国市场并将Laser Karaoke引入美国酒吧时，他们复制了同样的公式。他们以此在日本取得了巨大成功，并希望在美国复制他们的成功，他们觉得这是我们在日本的做法。我们在美国也必须以同样的方式做。但它不可能完全一样。
Those videos were shot in Japan, for Japanese songs, for a Japanese audience. You know, you couldn't have a song like, you know, I shot the sheriff with a Japanese video on it. It didn't work. You had to have a production company go out there and shoot the videos. Which is how people like Nori Niven got involved. I always compared it to like that scene in Conan the Barbarian where he has to push that rock in a circle for like 10 years before he becomes a grown man, you know, when he's all strong because you shoot
那些视频是在日本拍摄的，针对的是日本歌曲，面向日本观众。你知道的，你不能搞一首像《我枪毙了警长》（I Shot the Sheriff）那样配上日本视频的歌。这行不通。你必须找一家制作公司去实地拍摄视频。这就是像诺里·尼文（Nori Niven）这样的人如何参与其中的。我总是把它比作《野蛮人柯南》（Conan the Barbarian）里的那个场景，他必须推那块石头绕圈推大约10年，直到他成为一个成年人，你知道的，当他变得非常强壮的时候，因为你拍摄
a million feet of film and either you fail or you come out of it stronger. In the late 1980s, Noir was actually still in college. He'd been directing music videos for local artists when the opportunity
了一百万英尺的胶片，要么你失败了，要么你从失败中变得更强大。在20世纪80年代末，诺里其实还在上大学。他一直在为当地艺术家导演音乐录影带，这时参与这些视频制作的机会
to work on these karaoke videos fell into his lap. Somehow I wound up on a panel for music videos at Panavision in Dallas and I'm like 20 years old and one of the guys on the panel said, hey, I've got these karaoke videos.
从天而降。不知怎么的，我最后在达拉斯的潘那威视（Panavision）参加了一个关于音乐录影带的小组讨论，当时我大概20岁，小组中的一个人说，嘿，我有这些卡拉OK视频。
You want to think. come to shoot some of them, and I would shoot anything. I mean, I love shooting film, and the idea of shooting music videos sounded really fun, and of course I said yes. Pioneer had a division called Laserdisc Corporation of America, also known as LDCA. They contracted production companies and directors from Los Angeles, New York, Dallas, even London. And Norie remembers early on, there was one specific directive for these videos. They wanted stories. So I remember they. They really wanted a narrative weave.
你想来拍几个吗？而我什么都愿意拍。我的意思是，我喜欢拍胶片，而且拍音乐录影带的想法听起来非常有趣，当然我答应了。先锋公司有一个部门叫做美国激光视盘公司（Laserdisc Corporation of America），也称为LDCA。他们与来自洛杉矶、纽约、达拉斯甚至伦敦的制作公司和导演签约。诺里记得在早期，这些视频有一个具体的要求。他们想要故事。所以我记得他们。他们真的想要一个叙事织锦。
They wanted a beginning, a middle, and an end. They really wanted you to stick to the story line of the song. By the time Pioneer got into this, I think they needed to have some sort of story. Brian Raftery again. Because at that point, Western audiences, especially after seven or eight years of MTV, they knew that every video had to have either a wild collage or a very easy-to-follow narrative. Pioneer wanted these narratives to adhere to the vibe and message of the song, but that came with one big stipulation.
他们想要一个开头、一个过程和一个结尾。他们真的希望你紧跟歌曲的故事情节。等到先锋涉足这个领域时，我认为他们需要某种故事。再次是布赖恩·拉夫特里。因为在那个时候，西方观众，尤其是经过MTV七八年的洗礼后，他们知道每一个视频要么必须包含狂野的拼贴画，要么必须有一个非常容易理解的叙事。先锋希望这些叙事符合歌曲的氛围和信息，但这附带了一个大前提。
The footage used in these videos had to be completely original for copyright purposes. Pioneer only licensed the music, not the artist's likeness or any existing music video, so you couldn't reference their vision of the song. You know, if it was a song, if it was Thriller, they did not want you to do like the Thriller dance. They didn't want you to come to something original. There were, of course, a few other minor ground rules of what you could or could not show. I know they did not want people singing. I think that's one thing is to have no one singing along to the song,
出于版权目的，这些视频中使用的素材必须完全是原创的。先锋只获得了音乐的许可，没有获得艺术家的肖像权或任何现有的音乐录影带，所以你不能参考他们对这首歌的构想。你知道的，如果这是一首歌，如果是《颤栗》（Thriller），他们不希望你跳《颤栗》那样的舞蹈。他们不希望你——你得想出一些原创的东西。当然，关于你能展示什么或不能展示什么，还有一些其他的微小基本规则。我知道他们不希望人们唱歌。我想其中一点就是让任何人都不跟唱这首歌，
almost like not acknowledging that it's there because the focus should be on the singer. Pioneer also didn't want anything too violent or too salacious. I just had to keep it clean. So I had to be careful with, you know, nothing was too sexualized or whatever it was. Saad Nisheli was a producer at LDCA. She worked with dozens of directors during her time there
几乎就像不承认它的存在一样，因为重点应该放在歌手身上。先锋也不希望有任何过于暴力或过于淫秽的内容。我必须保持画面干净。所以我必须小心，你知道的，不能有太性感的元素之类的。萨德·尼谢利（Saad Nisheli）是LDCA的制作人。她在那里工作期间与几十位导演合作过，
and was a liaison between the higher-upset Pioneer and the production companies actually making the videos. It was a wild time where you kind of have, free rain. It was scary in a way, but it was also really a lot of fun. Sauna said that aside from those family-friendly rules, they almost never got any creative notes from the company. I don't think anyone was probably watching them except for us. Which also meant that the people making these videos had near complete artistic freedom. I don't even think that making a good karaoke video was the thing. It was just making good art,
并且是先锋高层与实际制作视频的制作公司之间的联络人。那是一个你可以说是享有绝对自由的疯狂时代。从某种程度上说这很可怕，但其实也非常有趣。萨娜说，除了那些适合家庭观看的规则之外，他们几乎从未收到过公司发来的任何创意修改意见。我想除了我们之外，可能没有人会看它们。这也意味着制作这些视频的人拥有近乎完全的艺术自由。我甚至认为制作一个好的卡拉OK视频并不是重点。重点只是创作好的艺术，
you know, not necessarily for karaoke. I don't think any of us had that in mind when we shot it. It was just making beautiful art. But that beautiful art came with a pretty big limitation. Pioneer was a huge company with capital to throw behind these new karaoke videos, but not like that much capital. In the late 80s and 90s, the average cost of a music video on MTV could run $50,000 to $60,000.
你知道的，不一定是为了卡拉OK。我想我们拍摄时谁也没有把那放在心上。这只是在创作美丽的艺术。但那美丽的艺术伴随着一个相当大的局限性。先锋是一家拥有资本来支持这些新卡拉OK视频的大公司，但也没有那么多资本。在80年代末和90年代，MTV上音乐录影带的平均成本可能达到50,000到60,000美元。
These karaoke videos, on the other hand, ranged from $3,600 to $10,000 because, well, this wasn't MTV. That budget had to cover production costs like locations, camera rentals, film stock in development, props, accrue, actors, and whatever payment you can walk away with for yourself. So these videos became a real filmmaking test of what directors could do with a micro-budget, limited resources, and the creative wiggle room to go wild.
另一方面，这些卡拉OK视频的费用在3,600到10,000美元之间，因为，好吧，这不是MTV。这个预算必须涵盖制作成本，比如场地、摄像机租赁、胶片及冲洗、道具、剧组、演员，以及你能带走的任何报酬。所以这些视频成了对电影制作人的一次真正的考验：在微薄的预算、有限的资源以及可以疯狂发挥的创意自由空间下，导演们到底能做出什么。
I mean, when the idea first came to you, where you're going to pay us to do this thing that it seems very clear that do you really need like a high production video? Like what were your thoughts when? Never even thought that just went, oh, great, brilliant, yes. You don't question at all. I wasn't biting the hand that fed. Yeah, I can do that.
我的意思是，当这个想法第一次出现时，他们要付钱让我们做这件事，这似乎很明显，你真的需要像高制作水准的视频吗？就像你当时的感想是什么？从没想过，只觉得，哦，太棒了，绝了，好极了。你一点也不会质疑。我不会砸了赏饭吃的手。好吧，我能做到。
And I like the sound of it. Let's do that. This is Nikki Smedley. She produced a handful of karaoke videos for Pioneer in London and has had a long career in entertainment. I started out as a dancer and an actress. I ran a cabaret club. I went on to be a telitubby and now I'd do one woman's show for grownups and that's me. You did hear that correctly. Nikki was one of the original teletubbies. She played Lala, the yellow one. I always say to people, I'm not famous. I just had one very famous outfit. So yeah, that's what I did. People won't recognize
而且我听着挺顺耳。那就这么干吧。这位是妮基·斯德利（Nikki Smedley）。她为先锋在伦敦制作了一小批卡拉OK视频，在娱乐界有着漫长的职业生涯。我最初是一名舞者和演员。我经营过一家歌舞俱乐部。后来我成了天线宝宝，现在我为成年人做单人脱口秀，这就是我。你确实没听错。妮基是最初的天线宝宝之一。她扮演拉拉，那个黄色的。我总是对人们说，我不出名。我只是穿过一套非常著名的服装。所以，是的，这就是我做的事。人们可能认不出
but they recognize me boy. At the time, Nikki had very little to no production experience. Her friend Neil was hired to direct some videos and brought her on as a producer and choreographer. I found her name on the credits for Pioneer Laserdisc Volume 307, which I was actually holding in my hand during our Zoom call. Well, I think you've got ain't nothing going on but the rent. I do. You recognize it from the back of the...
但我敢说他们绝对能认出我。当时，妮基几乎没有什么制作经验。她的朋友尼尔被雇来导演一些视频，并把她拉来担任制作人和编舞。我在先锋激光视盘第307辑的演职员表中找到了她的名字，我在我们进行Zoom通话时其实正把它拿在手里。好吧，我想你拿的是《除了房租什么也没有》（Ain't Nothing Going On But the Rent）。我确实拿著。你从背面认出了……
Nikki instantly clocked the Laserdisc volume in my hand. And a song for a video she worked on called Ain't Nothing Going On But the Rent. That's the first one that Neil and I did working together. If you've never heard it, it's an R&B song by Gwen Guthrie about a woman looking for a man who's, at the very least, financially stable. No romance without finances the refrain. Nikki and her director Neil, on the other hand, plotted out a different story for the video. It was about a couple who throw a house party in order to come up with money for rent.
妮基一眼就认出了我手中的激光视盘，以及她参与制作的一个名为《除了房租什么也没有》的视频的歌曲。那是尼尔和我合作制作的第一部作品。如果你从没听过，这是一首由格温·格思里（Gwen Guthrie）演唱的R&B歌曲，讲述了一个寻找至少在经济上稳定的男人的女人。“没有资金就没有浪漫”是其中的副歌。另一方面，妮基和她的导演尼尔为视频策划了一个不同的故事。讲的是一对夫妇举办了一场家庭派对来筹集房租。
It's definitely a different interpretation of the song's original meaning, but it works. She broke down the process of how that video was planned. I would have a meeting with Neil and give him a general idea, and we would talk through the different shots that we thought we needed, and yes, and start doing a bit of loose budgeting coming for what we need. And then at the same time, I would be working with the music and drawing, like I have like a kind of beat map of the construction of the song. And then we'd meet up with a cameraman and go, this is what we want,
这绝对是对歌曲原本含义的一种不同解读，但它行之有效。她详细拆解了该视频的策划过程。我会和尼尔开会，给他一个大致的想法，然后我们讨论我们认为需要的不同镜头，是的，开始为我们所需的东西做一个大致的预算。然后与此同时，我会研究音乐并画画，比如我有一种歌曲结构的节奏图。然后我们会和摄像师见面并讨论，这就是我们想要的，
maybe have to make or find some props. And then go, voila. It has a look of any British synth pop video you might see on MTV in the 1980s. High contrast lighting, graphic wipes, glamorous, melancholy. If you blinked, you might think you were watching a Kajuku music video. And it went down so brilliantly well that they asked us to do more, so we started a little company. In order to keep things within budget, producers needed to get creative. They'd borrow a friend's apartment to shoot in, or work out deals with actors trying to get footage for a demo reel,
可能还需要制作或寻找一些道具。然后说，瞧！它有着你在20世纪80年代MTV上可能看到的任何英国合成流行音乐视频的风格。高对比度照明、图形划像、迷人、忧郁。如果你眨一下眼，你可能会以为自己在看Kajagoogoo乐队的音乐录影带。它取得了巨大的成功，以至于他们要求我们拍更多，于是我们开了一家小公司。为了把开支控制在预算之内，制作人们需要发挥创意。他们会借朋友的公寓来拍摄，或者与正为试镜带寻找素材的演员达成交易，
or stack shoots on top of each other so they could reuse the same sets and crews for multiple videos. I remember mostly in the early days. You're just getting stuff shoved at you. Norie Nibben again. He says that it wasn't exactly a glamorous life in the beginning. We had a stage, and in order to shoot on the stage, we had to shoot like four in one day, I'm literally not sleeping and trying to shoot in 24 hours before you. It was just stupid.
或者把拍摄日程堆叠在一起，以便他们可以为多个视频重复使用相同的布景和剧组。我记得在早期大部分时间里。你只是不断被塞各种活儿。又是诺里·尼文。他说一开始的生活绝对称不上光鲜亮丽。我们有一个摄影棚，为了在摄影棚里拍摄，我们不得不在一天内拍四部，我 literalmente（字面意思）不睡觉，试图在你之前24小时内拍完。这简直蠢透了。
And why? Because we had a soundstage. But despite the slog of it all, Nori was really grateful for an opportunity like this. Learning how to shoot a film is incredibly expensive. And Pioneer was basically subsidizing the whole process. Nori directed a ton of videos for Pioneer, and he was always experimenting with technique. His videos always had different types of color grading or frame rates or transitions. He took advantage of those three minutes of laser disk space to create something interesting.
为什么呢？因为我们有一个录音棚。但尽管这一切繁重枯燥，诺里对能有这样一次机会仍然非常感激。学习如何拍电影的成本高得惊人。而先锋基本上是在补贴整个过程。诺里为先锋导演了大量视频，他一直在试验各种技术。他的视频总是采用不同类型的调色、帧率或转接过渡。他充分利用激光视盘那三分钟的空间来创作有趣的东西。
We shot on black and white, on reversal film stocks. We would load the film backwards. We baked the film. We pushed exposures. We did everything you could imagine experimental-wise just to push it, just to see what we could do to try to create different looks and different styles. It really pushed the science of film just to go for it. After the break, the rise and inevitable fall of the karaoke video Golden Age.
我们用黑白片、反转片胶片拍摄。我们会把胶片倒着装。我们会烤胶片。我们会推冲感光。我们在实验方面做了你能想象到的一切，只是为了推动极限，看看我们能做些什么来尝试创造不同的外观和风格。它真的把电影科学推向了极限，只管放手去干。休息过后，卡拉OK视频黄金时代的崛起与不可避免的衰落。
Stay with us. By the early 1990s, Pioneers Marketing Execke Neil Altnew says that the company was doing exactly what they had hoped. They were selling a ton of these karaoke laser discs, and they were making a lot of money. Let me tell you, when I started back in 1988, we had zero volume coming in. Two years later, we were in the millions.
请继续收听。到20世纪90年代初，先锋的市场营销高管尼尔·阿尔特纽表示，公司正在做他们一直期望的事情。他们卖出了大量的卡拉OK激光视盘，并且赚了很多钱。我得告诉你，当我1988年刚开始时，我们的销量为零。两年后，我们就达到了数百万。
They just couldn't wait for that next laser disk to come. They didn't care what was on it. They just needed to have the next one. So I would get 5,000 discs on an initial order. They were gone. They were already sold before I even got them. It was like watching a serial on HBO, like, you know, Game of Thrones,
他们简直等不及下一张激光视盘的问世。他们根本不在乎里面有什么。他们只想要下一张。所以我初次订货就能订到5,000张光盘。它们瞬间就没了。甚至在我拿到货之前就已经卖光了。这就像看HBO的连续剧一样，你知道的，比如《权力的游戏》，
and you can't wait until the next episode comes. It was the same thing with the laser disc. But Neil says that he actually doesn't think the karaoke videos were part of the success of laser disks. If anything, the videos were kind of an afterthought. His take is that laser discs were flying off the shelves because they were just a good product. Like for one, Pioneer was able to license an incredible library of music. Their discs had tracks for current popular songs, old standards, classics, something for everyone. I got disc one, the first one that was ever made.
你等不及下一集的到来。激光视盘也是如此。但尼尔说，他其实并不认为卡拉OK视频是激光视盘成功的一部分。如果要说的话，这些视频有点像是事后诸葛亮般的附加产物。他的看法是，激光视盘之所以热销，只是因为它们是一个好产品。比如首先，先锋能够获得令人难以置信的音乐曲库授权。他们的光盘里有当前流行歌曲、老牌标准曲、经典的曲目，适合每个人。我有第一张光盘，有史以来制作的第一张，
and on side A, they had a really good cross-section of music. On side A was rock around the clock, great balls of fire, long-tall Sally, can't keep a fall in love with you, Michelle, eight days a week. These are all Beatles songs that they gave us. Also, Neil and his division at Pioneer were doing exactly what they were supposed to, marketing this product out in the field. He says that they were going out into the trenches to convince bars around New York City to adopt their karaoke system.
而在A面上，他们拥有非常出色的音乐拼盘。A面上是《全天候摇滚》（Rock Around the Clock）、《大火球》（Great Balls of Fire）、《高个子萨莉》（Long Tall Sally）、《不能不坠入爱河》（Can't Help Falling in Love）、《米歇尔》（Michelle）、《一周八天》（Eight Days a Week）。这些全都是他们授权给我们的披头士歌曲。此外，尼尔和他在先锋的部门正在做他们应该做的事情，在实地营销这款产品。他说他们深入一线，说服纽约市周围的酒吧采用他们的卡拉OK系统。
And we said to them, look, we got this thing. The customers will be entertaining customers. So they'll be buying drinks. They'll be doing everything. It'll be good for you, a good business. And what we're going to do is we'll give you the equipment, we'll give you the software, we'll teach you how to use it. The only thing we ask is if you're successful,
我们对他们说，看，我们有这个东西。顾客会娱乐顾客。所以他们会买酒。他们会做各种事情。这对你很好，是一笔好生意。我们要做的就是，我们把设备交给你，我们把软件交给你，我们教你如何使用它。我们唯一的请求是，如果你成功了，
we're allowed to bring other people in to show the success that we're having with the karaoke. Word spread, karaoke spread. And it got the point where karaoke was being done seven nights a week. in Manhattan. Karaoke was so popular, it was essentially keeping laser disc technology afloat in the 90s. It was also generating a ton of work
我们获准带其他人进来，展示我们在卡拉OK上取得的成功。消息传开了，卡拉OK普及了。甚至到了在曼哈顿每周七天都有人唱卡拉OK的地步。卡拉OK是如此受欢迎，它基本上在90年代支撑着激光视盘技术勉强维持。它还为制作公司创造了大量的工作机会。
for the production companies. Pioneer printed at least 80 laser disc volumes in the original English language series alone, each one with 28 tracks disc. This meant that literally thousands of original karaoke videos needed to be produced alongside those tracks. You know, it had reached a peak
先锋仅在最初的英语系列中就至少印制了80个激光视盘音轨系列，每盘有28个音轨。这意味着数以千计的原创卡拉OK视频需要与这些音轨一起制作。你知道的，它已经达到了顶峰，
and there was a lot of money and there was a lot of stuff going into the production. Nori and I flew to Paris for one of them. I mean, it's crazy, you know, for a karaoke video. But it was beautiful, you know. Culture writer Brian Raftery refuses to call himself a karaoke expert, but he does have a shed crammed full of these discs at his house and has logged an ungodly amount of hours watching these videos.
有很多资金投入，也有很多东西投入到制作中。诺里和我为此飞去巴黎拍其中一个。我的意思是，这太疯狂了，你知道的，为了一个卡拉OK视频。但它真的很美，你知道的。文化作家布赖恩·拉夫特里拒绝称自己为卡拉OK专家，但他的家里确实有一个塞满这些光盘的小屋，并且记录了极其惊人的观看这些视频的小时数。
Oh, my God. It's probably probably one of those things where if I got to have, and an afterlife and they gave you like a rundown of what you did, I think that would be like the one regret where I'm like, I spent how many hours? I mean, I guess it's in the hundreds of hours range. And it was during these hundreds of hours that he started noticing some bizarre subgenres across the pioneer karaoke uvra. There were, of course, the things you might expect from your 80s music video, women dancing in fluorescent unitards and brooding men on motorcycles. But Brian also picked up on the fact that a lot of these videos were definitely filmed at the tail end of the Reagan administration. There's so many 80s yuppie karaoke videos where it's like a guy in a convertible and he's driving to like a bluff to go to his house on Malibu and he's got blondes in his car. It's just like this weird 80s idea of excess and success.
哦，天哪。这大概可能是那种事情，如果我有来生，而他们给你一份你所做事情的总结清单，我想那会是我唯一后悔的事，我会觉得，我花了多少个小时？我的意思是，我想这应该在几百小时的范围内。正是在这几百小时里，他开始注意到先锋卡拉OK作品中出现的一些奇特的亚流派。当然，有你可能从80年代音乐录影带中预期的那些东西，穿着荧光紧身衣跳舞的女人和骑着摩托车沉思的男人。但布赖恩也注意到一个事实，许多这些视频绝对是在里根政府执政末期拍摄的。有那么多80年代的雅皮士卡拉OK视频，比如一个家伙开着敞篷车，正开车去马里布的悬崖边上的房子，他的车里还坐着金发女郎。这就像是80年代对过度消费和成功的奇特想象。
I call them serial killers. Norie Niven again. I thought that all the love songs, the male actors they hired looked like they wanted to kill everyone. When they look like they were in love, it just looked like they wanted to kill everyone. There was also the genre of videos that Brian describes as the first three minutes of a porno. Nothing explicit, just the exposition. The whole era of like these couples that were kind of either together or wandering around the city, they're either like grand sweeping pastoral nature scenes where they're both on horses together on the beach
我称它们为连环杀手。又是诺里·尼文。我觉得所有的情歌中，他们雇用的男演员看起来都像是想杀了所有人。当他们看起来像是坠入爱河时，那表情简直就像是想杀光所有人。还有一类视频，被布赖恩描述为“色情片的前三分钟”。没有什么露骨的，只有铺垫。整个时代就像这些情侣，要么在一起，要么在城市里游荡，要么是宏大开阔的田园风光场景，两人一起骑着马在海滩上，
or they're like walking through and like wearing incredibly boxy suits, both the man and the woman, like very, very boxy lady's power suits. And they're not pornographic or skin flicky, but they're definitely like, this is the beginning. of their romantic night. Looking back now, I've never thought about this, but people talk about boomers a lot now. If you want to know about the boomer life in the 80s, I think these karaoke videos,
要么他们走来走去，穿着极具棱角的西装，无论是男人还是女人，都穿着非常非常方正的女士权力套装。它们不是色情片或软性色情片，但它们绝对是那种：这是他们浪漫之夜的开始。现在回想起来，我从来没想过这一点，但人们现在经常谈论婴儿潮一代。如果你想了解80年代婴儿潮一代的生活，我想这些卡拉OK视频，
it's like a lot of middle-aged guys in convertibles, a lot of couples wearing boxy suits, walking around forever. It's like, it's an interesting look at what boomers did before they found Facebook, I guess. It's like they love, they live, they rode horseback, they had sat in sheets. They had very big lives.
就像许多中年男子开着敞篷车，许多情侣穿着方正的西装，永远在四处闲逛。这就好像，这是对婴儿潮一代在发现脸书之前所作所为的一个有趣审视，我猜。就好像他们爱过，他们生活过，他们骑过马，他们躺过床单。他们过着非常宏大的生活。
This is why they're so angry now, I get it. In Brian's opinion, the very best karaoke videos were the ones that were absolutely uncategorizable. The ones with storylines that were so nuts or so irrelevant to the song itself that you couldn't help but turn your head towards the screen. There was some stupid things that were done. Neil Altnew clearly does not share this opinion. Despite Pioneer not really intervening much on creative, Neil says that of course these videos had to at least be reviewed. And for the most part, he wasn't super impressed. I've got to be honest with you.
这就是为什么他们现在这么生气，我懂了。在布赖恩看来，最好的卡拉OK视频是那些完全无法归类的视频。那些故事情节如此疯狂或与歌曲本身如此不相关，以至于你忍不住把头转向屏幕。有些事情做得挺蠢的。尼尔·阿尔特纽显然没有这种看法。尽管先锋在创意上没有真正过多干预，但尼尔说，当然，这些视频至少必须经过审核。而且大部分时间，他并没有留下特别深刻的印象。说实话，
These production companies, they made these videos, and they really didn't look at the music that well because a lot of these videos really didn't fit the music. One video for the Cheers theme song, which is a television show about a group of regulars at a bar, had a storyline where a man gets thrown into a jail cell full of scary-looking inmates. But instead of getting the crap kicked out of him,
这些制作公司，他们制作了这些视频，但他们真的没有把音乐研究透，因为很多这些视频真的跟音乐不搭。Cheers（干杯）主题曲的一个视频，这是一个关于酒吧常客群体的电视剧，其情节是一个男人被扔进了一个满是面目可憎的囚犯的监狱牢房里。但并没有遭到一顿暴打，
everyone breaks into spontaneous dance. It was one where they had the two Barbie dolls. they were showing. And it was a love song and they had the, somebody was holding them in their hand and they had the Barbie dolls kissing each other. There's one where it's just like a woman feeding a goose seductively or something like that and we're just like, what is this gem? In one surreal video for the song Israelites by Desmond Decker, a man in shirtless overalls uses a pickaxe to turn a lump of salt into bread while small children attempt to hoist him into the air with a play parachute, which is so David Lynchie and I half expected Laura Dern to show up.
而是所有人突然跳起舞来。其中一个是他们展示了两个芭比娃娃。这是一个情歌，有人把它们拿在手里，让芭比娃娃互相亲吻。还有一个视频，只是一个女人在诱惑性地喂一只鹅什么的，我们就在想，这到底是什么神仙宝藏？在一个超现实的视频中，伴随着德斯蒙德·德克尔（Desmond Decker）的歌曲《以色列人》（Israelites），一个光着膀子穿着背带裤的男人用镐把一块盐变成面包，而小孩子们试图用游乐园的降落伞把他抬到空中，这太具大卫·林奇（David Lynchie）风格了，我甚至半信半疑地期待劳拉·邓恩（Laura Dern）出现。
The conversation between the song and the video, I guess you could say, we're not always in the same room, tune, or key, but they didn't always make sense of the songs they were going along with, but they were amazing to watch. While several of these music videos were insane or cheesy or just aged poorly, like don't get me started on the video for David Bowie's China Girl, a lot were actually made well. Many were shot on film stock, well-lit,
可以说，歌曲和视频之间的对话，并不总是在同一个房间、同一个曲调或同一个调性里，但它们并不总是与所伴随的歌曲相契合，然而观看它们却是一件妙不可事的事情。虽然其中几个音乐录影带疯狂、俗气，或者只是年久失修显得过时——比如别让我开始吐槽大卫·Bowie（David Bowie）的《中国女孩》（China Girl）的视频——但很多其实制作得很精良。许多是用胶片拍摄的，打光很好，
and you could tell that the people who made them took this as an opportunity to practice a craft. And because Pioneer hired production companies from all over the country, lots of different types of people had the opportunity to try this work on for size. There were camera people, production designers, grips, makeup artists, actors,
你能看出制作它们的人把这当作练习手艺的机会。而且因为先锋聘请了来自全国各地的制作公司，许多不同类型的人都有机会尝试这种工作。有摄像师、美术指导、灯光助理、化妆师、演员，
and some of them eventually went on to do big things in entertainment. I think one of the Dixie chicks wound up in a video apparently. You know, Dylan McDermott may have been in one, if I remember correctly. Dermot Roney. Oh my God. I mean, Dermalroni may have, too. I mean, Bill Paxson and Bill Pullman may have done these. I don't know. One producer on a ton of karaoke videos named Paris Barkley was eventually elected as president of the Directors Guild of America. And Nory Niven, who you've been hearing from, has been a successful commercial director for around 30 years now.
其中一些人后来在娱乐界干出了大事业。我想迪克西女子合唱团（Dixie Chicks）的一个成员最后好像也出现在了一个视频里。你知道的，迪伦·麦克德莫特（Dylan McDermott）可能也演过一个，如果我没记错的话。德莫特·罗尼（Dermot Rooney）。哦，天哪。我的意思是，德莫特·罗尼可能也演过。我的意思是，比尔·帕克斯顿（Bill Paxton）和比尔·普尔曼（Bill Pullman）可能也拍过这些。我不知道。曾参与大量卡拉OK视频制作的制作人帕里斯·巴克利（Paris Barkley）后来当选为美国导演工会（Directors Guild of America）主席。而你一直听到的诺里·尼文，大约30年来一直是一名成功的商业片导演。
Brian Raftery also spotted a pretty prominent name listed on the credits on a couple of these videos. Jay Roach, who directed Austin Powers and many other big movies, he's. His name is on one or two of these things, maybe more than that. I directed two videos. One was based on the Barbara Streisand song. I am a woman in love, and the other one was based on my funny Valentine. This is Jay Roach. As Brian mentioned, he directed the Austin Powers films, also The Roses, as well as Meet the Parents.
布赖恩·拉夫特里还在其中几个视频的演职员表里发现了一个相当显赫的名字。执导了《王牌大贱谍》（Austin Powers）和许多其他大片的杰伊·罗奇（Jay Roach），他的。他的名字出现在其中一两个视频上，也许还不止这些。我导演了两个视频。一个是基于芭芭拉·史翠珊（Barbra Streisand）的歌曲《我是一个坠入爱河的女人》（I Am a Woman in Love），另一个是基于《我可笑的情人节》（My Funny Valentine）。这位是杰伊·罗奇。正如布赖恩所提到的，他执导了《王牌大贱谍》系列电影，还有《恩怨情天》（The Roosevelts），以及《拜见岳父大人》（Meet the Parents）。
It's kind of funny because he would actually go from directing a Barbara Streisand karaoke video to later directing Barbara Streisand herself. You know, I worked with her on Meet the Poker's later. and if I had remembered, I would have embarrassed myself until I did that video. He was still a grad student at the time when he was given the chance to make a couple of these videos. And apparently, these karaoke videos are some of the very first short films he ever directed. I'm sure those were my first paid gigs directing anything for sure. So it might have been kind of steps across that threshold,
这有点搞笑，因为他实际上是从导演芭芭拉·史翠珊的卡拉OK视频，到后来导演芭芭拉·史翠珊本人。你知道的，我后来在《拜见岳父大人》里和她合作过，如果我当时还记得的话，在我拍那个视频之前，我肯定会尴尬得无地自容。他当时还是一名研究生，得到了制作其中几个视频的机会。显然，这些卡拉OK视频是他导演的早期一些短片。我敢确定那些绝对是我导演生涯中最初获得报酬的工作。所以这可能有点像迈过那个门槛的步伐，
because I really never considered myself a director until I just started doing it. He says that he had always seen himself as more of a cinematographer, the technical person who hid behind the camera. But because the stakes and the budget of these music videos were so low, he was kind of forced to give directing actors a try. Directing actors as a young person, as a new person, is probably the most intimidating thing. I knew about camera, I knew about sound and editing and everything else, but I hadn't really worked with actors that much. So it also gave me a chance to just try that. Can we say that if it weren't for karaoke videos, we wouldn't have the Austin Powers films? Of course. Would it be true? Probably not. Jay Roach is a talented guy who would have figured out how to direct either way.
因为在真正开始做之前，我从来没把自己当成过导演。他说他一直觉得自己更像是一个摄影师，一个藏在摄像机后面的技术人员。但因为这些音乐录影带的赌注和预算都非常低，他可以说是被迫尝试去指导演员。作为一个年轻人、一个新人去指导演员，可能是最让人畏惧的事情。我懂摄影、懂声音、懂剪辑以及其他一切，但我并没有真正跟演员合作过那么多。所以这也是一个让我去尝试的机会。我们能否说，如果没有卡拉OK视频，就不会有《王牌大贱谍》系列电影？当然可以。这会是真的吗？可能不会。杰伊·罗奇是一个才华横溢的人，无论如何他都会搞清楚怎么当导演。
But talking to him, he seems to have the same gratitude for these videos as everyone else I spoke with for this story. Every opportunity to make something is a chance to learn. And he's carried a little bit of those early karaoke lessons with him throughout his career. You have to develop a little bit of tolerance from misery when you make movies. I mean, it's obviously a lucky thing to get to do, but there's never enough budget. There's never enough time. You're always trying to do something, you know, again, that may exceed your resources and exceed your own capabilities. So it was an accidental film school in a way.
但与他交谈时，他对这些视频表现出的感激之情与我为这个故事采访的其他人如出一辙。每一个创作的机会都是学习的机会。他在整个职业生涯中一直随身带着那些早期的卡拉OK课程。你在拍电影时必须培养对痛苦的一点点容忍度。我的意思是，能做这行显然是一件幸运的事，但预算永远不够。时间永远不够。你知道的，你总是在试图做一些可能超出你的资源、超出你自身能力的事情。所以从某种意义上说，这是一所偶然的电影学校。
It was an accidental opportunity that turned out to be, you know, good for everybody involved. But the karaoke video Golden Age couldn't last forever. And ironically, a big reason why it was doomed was the very same reason why it caught on, the music. I say this transition really started to happen in 1994, where you could start seeing the karaoke business going down. When the Laser Karaoke Division started back in 1988, Pioneer was able to license a ton of popular music, but they only licensed those songs for around seven years. Maybe it was because karaoke was so new and unknown to music publishers, but it was a lot easier to secure the rights at those early stages. By the time those licenses expired,
这是一个偶然的机会，结果证明对（参与其中的）每个人都有好处。但卡拉OK视频的黄金时代不可能永远持续下去。具有讽刺意味的是，它注定走向没落的一个重要原因，正是它最初走红的原因：音乐。我认为这种转变真正开始于1994年，当时你可以开始看到卡拉OK业务在走下坡路。当激光卡拉OK部门在1988年刚开始时，先锋能够授权大量的流行音乐，但他们只将这些歌曲授权了大约七年。也许是因为卡拉OK对于音乐出版商来说太新、太陌生了，但在早期阶段获得版权要容易得多。等到这些授权到期时，
publishers either didn't want to renew them or charged way more money to use those tracks. We had, like, I'm looking at disc three, there's 28 songs on it, so they had to come out with a disc where they had to take maybe five songs off the disc because they weren't licensed anymore. But the final nail in the coffin for pioneer laser karaoke ended up being an emerging media format called CD Plus Graphics or CDG. CDG was basically, a regular audio CD that was capable of displaying very simple graphics on a screen. They weren't advanced enough to show something like a full-on movie, but they were capable of displaying lyrics synced to a song. They were also a fraction of the price of Laserdisc. Video production
出版商要么不想续签，要么要求支付更高的费用来使用这些音轨。我正在看第三张盘，上面有28首歌，所以他们不得不发行一张盘，里面必须去掉大约五首歌，因为它们不再受版权保护了。但是先锋激光卡拉OK的致命一击，最终是一个被称为CD附加图形或CDG的新兴媒体格式。CDG基本上是一张普通的音频CD，能够在屏幕上显示非常简单的图形。它们没有先进到可以显示像完整电影这样的内容，但它们能够显示与歌曲同步的歌词。它们的价格也只是激光影碟的一小部分。视频制作
got hit immediately. Oh, it was a train wreck. Norie Niven and Sad Nishelly both had a view from inside the train as it was crashing. I remember I was in a loft downtown. And the guy came in from L.A. And, oh, gosh. And he was like, he said, we're going to cut the budgets in half. And we'd like for you to start using stock footage.
遭受了即时打击。哦，简直是一场列车失事。诺里·尼文和萨德·尼谢利都从列车撞毁的内部看到了这一幕。我记得我当时在市中心的一个阁楼里。有个家伙从洛杉矶赶来。哦，天哪。他说，我们要把预算削减一半。我们希望你们开始使用素材视频。
How much stock footage can you cram into these things? And I was like, oh, my gosh, red flags everywhere. It just kind of got to that point where we were shooting scenic stuff. And it just wasn't as fun. There wasn't as much budget anymore. And I was like, I'm out. Nothing looked good at that point. So we politely resigned to job.
你能把多少素材视频塞进这些东西里？我当时想，天哪，到处都是危险信号。事情发展到我们只拍摄风景的地步。而且没那么有趣了。预算也不那么充足了。我当时想，我不干了。那时候什么看起来都不好。所以我们礼貌地辞去了工作。
Eventually, they became the worst kind of karaoke video. Boring. Just stock footage of people walking in a park, by the ocean, on the street, the kinds of videos that I remember watching as a kid. Pioneer released their last English-language karaoke laser disc in 1999 and announced the end of all laser disc products in 2009. You know, flame went out. But it was a fun ride.
最终，它们变成了最糟糕的那种卡拉OK视频。无聊。只有人们在公园里、海边、街上散步的素材视频，这种视频我记得小时候看过。先锋公司于1999年发布了他们的最后一张英语卡拉OK激光影碟，并于2009年宣布结束所有激光影碟产品。你知道，火熄灭了。但这是一段快乐的旅程。
It really was a fun ride. Neil Altnew stayed with the company until 2008, and he thinks that had Pioneer come out with their karaoke products on CDG format from the beginning, karaoke would have probably been just as popular. When I was singing or when most people sing, they don't even look at the videos. You know, they're looking at the words because they want to get the right words, because nobody cared about the videos. That could be true.
这确实是一段快乐的旅程。尼尔·阿尔特纽在公司呆到了2008年，他认为如果先锋公司从一开始就推出CDG格式的卡拉OK产品，卡拉OK可能也会同样受欢迎。当我在唱歌或者大多数人唱歌的时候，他们甚至不看视频。你知道，他们看的是歌词，因为他们想得到正确的歌词，因为没有人关心视频。这可能是真的。
And had Pioneer not commissioned their karaoke videos, they would have saved millions of dollars. But in making these laser disks, they provided a lot of people with something that seems increasingly rare these days, the opportunity to make something cool. I think if they were inventing karaoke in these days, they'd never even think to put a video there
如果先锋公司没有委托制作他们的卡拉OK视频，他们本可以省下数百万美元。但在制作这些激光影碟的过程中，他们为很多人提供了一种如今似乎越来越罕见的东西——创造酷炫事物的机会。我想如果他们是在今天发明卡拉OK，他们甚至永远不会考虑在里面放一个视频
because that wouldn't be the motivation. The motivation would be how to do it the most profitably rather than creating something more interesting. Nikki Smedley again. She was the producer that worked on these videos in London. And in case you forgot, was also a f***ing telitubby. Nikki still works in the arts. She practically has her whole life.
因为那不是动力。动力将是如何以最高利润的方式来做这件事，而不是创造更有趣的东西。再次是尼基·斯梅德利。她是在伦敦参与制作这些视频的制片人。如果你忘了的话，她还是个该死的天线宝宝。尼基现在仍然从事艺术工作。她几乎一辈子都在这样做。
And she says that it was a blessing to receive even a little bit of money to support herself when she was younger. When you asked me about whether or not I questioned it, you just went, no. No, that's great. It's a creative thing. It's working with my pals. It's doing what I love.
她说，年轻时哪怕能得到一点点资金支持来养活自己，也是一种福气。当你们问我是否曾经质疑过它时，你们只是说，不。不，这太棒了。这是一件有创意的事情。这是和伙伴们一起工作。这是在做我热爱的事情。
It's making things out of nothing. thing to music. Tick. Yeah, absolutely. Every single bit of paid work that I got in those days was, yeah, that was manner from heaven, completely and utterly. Actually, I have got a question, which is why are you interested, I suppose. I got asked this question a lot as I was sending emails to the legends of karaoke past. And yes, the idea of talking about weird-ass karaoke key music videos was the initial draw. But really, I think it's probably because I wish I could have been there. I originally moved to Los Angeles to work in production, and had Pioneers still been
这是用无中生有。做成音乐。打勾。是的，完全正确。我在那些日子里得到的每一笔有报酬的工作，是的，那简直是天赐的甘露，完完全全、彻头彻尾的。其实，我有一个问题，那就是为什么你们会感兴趣，我想。当我给过去的卡拉OK传奇人物发送电子邮件时，我经常被问到这个问题。是的，谈论奇怪的卡拉OK音乐视频的想法最初是吸引力所在。但真的，我想可能是因为我希望我也能在那里。我最初搬到洛杉矶是为了从事制作工作，如果先锋公司还在
commissioning these videos, I 1,000% would have done this. Making even the worst short films is so hard and so expensive and so exhausting, and I loved it so much. I'm kind of in awe that at one point, a whole artistic industry existed where people got paid and people got to take chances, and it was all because an electronics company wanted to sell some laser discs. Well, as you know very well, it was a relatively short period of time that they were prepared to pay out for these videos to happen.
委托制作这些视频，我百分之千会做这件事。制作哪怕是最糟糕的短片也是如此艰难、如此昂贵、如此令人精疲力竭，但我太爱它了。我有点惊叹于曾经存在过这样一个艺术行业，人们能拿到报酬，人们能去冒险，而这一切都只是因为一家电子公司想要卖出一些激光影碟。好吧，正如你非常清楚的，他们准备为这些视频的制作支付费用的时间相对较短。
And just a little breaking wave, we managed to surf. Karaoke, as a form of entertainment, of course, made it out of this period just fine. It's been surfing the wave of technology from the very first machine to eight tracks to laser disc to CDG to being available on every single phone because of YouTube. Singing at the top of our lungs in a dark room with our best friends is a pastime that will never go out of style. But for a very brief, spectacular moment, karaoke also created an opportunity for a lot of people to explore something they loved and make something that they cared about. even if no one was watching. 99% Invisible was produced this week by me, Vivian Lay, and edited by our senior editor Delaney Hall.
就像我们设法冲浪的一个小破浪。卡拉OK作为一种娱乐形式，当然安然度过了这段时期。它一直在冲浪技术的浪潮，从第一台机器到八音轨，到激光影碟，再到CDG，直到因为YouTube而在每一部手机上都能使用。在黑暗的房间里和我们最好的朋友放声歌唱是一种永远不会过时的消遣。但对于一个极其短暂而壮观的时刻，卡拉OK也为许多人创造了一个机会去探索他们所爱的事物并制作他们所关心的事情。即使没有人观看。《99%隐形》本周由我，维维安·莱制作，由我们的资深编辑德莱尼·霍尔编辑。
Mixed by Martine Gonzalez. Music by Swan Royale, George Langford, and Jamila Sandoto. Backchecking by Graham Hesha. Special thanks this week to Hardy Haberman and Jackson Roach. Brian Raftery has a new book out now about, of all things, Hannibal Lecter. It's called Hannibal Lecter A Life. Also if at any point during this episode you found yourself wondering, I wonder what it's like to play a telitubby.
由马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。音乐由天鹅皇家、乔治·兰格福德和贾米拉·桑多托提供。由格雷姆·赫沙核实事实。本周特别感谢哈迪·哈伯曼和杰克逊·罗奇。布赖恩·拉夫里现在有一本关于汉尼拔·莱克特的新书。书名叫《汉尼拔·莱克特的一生》。另外，如果在这一集的任何时候你发现自己想知道，我想知道扮演天线宝宝是什么感觉。
Well, you're in luck. Nikki Smetley also has a book. It's called Over the Hills and Far Away, My Life as a Telatubi. It is a delightful read, so you should check it out. Kathy 2 is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad, as our digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Brubay, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lachamadon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn and Rain Stradley,
好吧，你走运了。尼基·斯梅德利也有一本书。书名叫《翻过山丘，远走高飞：我作为天线宝宝的生活》。这是一本令人愉快的读物，所以你应该去看看。凯西2是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·布鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉查马顿、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔林和雷恩·斯特德利，
and the boss man, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all of the usual social media sites, as well as our Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有老板罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们现在是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心上城区的潘多拉大楼向北六个街区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的Discord服务器上找到我们。在99PI.org上有通往该链接以及99PI每一期往期节目的链接。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。